patrick queyras bonjour merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
on a vu des attaques répétées contre les
populations comment on peut expliquer
cette situation
il faut faire très attention à la
propagande qu'elle soit de dd dans les
deux sens et que ce soit celle la région
et y sommes c'est le gouvernement on n'a
pas beaucoup d'éléments pour aller
vérifier ce qui est dit donc il faut
faire il faut être très prudent s'il
faut pas il faut pas oublier c'est que
lorsque mois de novembre ammi ahmed a
décidé d'aller en guerre contre la
région du tigré il s'est entouré de
l'armée érythréenne de milices amara
même si 2010 à fars donc à partir ou à
la 2e étape puis koffi saouler les
tigres et ont repris l'ascendant ils
sont allés se protéger en faisant des
incursions région afar et amara c'est
donc un peu l'objet de notre reportage
donc ils sont allés si l'on peut dire
défaire les milices qui sont de toute
heure dans la bas le gros problème de
l'ethiopie c'est que chaque région a ses
propres milices qui sont plus ou moins
habillé en uniforme et on ne peut pas
trop toujours savoir qui sont les vrais
ou les mauvais si l'on peut lier voilà
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle les
tirs et 1 pour se protéger pour fait des
incursions en région afar et amar et
c'est la raison pour laquelle comme
lisez votre reportage ils sont venus
faire un petit peu la protection de la
région thies graille en étant beaucoup
plus à l'extérieur de la région qu'il ne
l'était au départ et c'est l'offensive
ont sorti ces populations créé leur
propre mélisme s qu'elles sont en mesure
de se défendre
dans ce sont des milices ce village de
villageois vous savez c'est un petit peu
quand même un peu partout en afrique où
vous allez vous protéger le village mais
ça s'arrête là donc ces quelques petites
armes de poing si l'on peut dire qu'elle
que ma chaîne et ça s'arrête là sont pas
les frais milices que l'on retrouve dans
des régions dans toutes les régions et à
l'ethiopie s'est redit région et à vous
avez des éléments armés nous avons aussi
des forces spéciales donc ça n'a rien à
voir son église de villageois ça va être
là pour protéger simplement quelques
fermes s'arrêtera là donc il n'y a pas
beaucoup de volonté de ces gens là
d'aller faire la guerre ce sera pas du
tout le cas des autres milices le menu
qu'ils qualifient de blocus se manie
terre de facto la situation subie par
par le tigre et qu'en est il réellement
habitant la région état du tigre à elle
est sous blocus depuis depuis 11 mois
pratiquement c'est ce que reprochent les
nations unies en mettant comme nations
unies la semaine dernière ont reproché à
l'habitude puis d'avoir expulsé un
certain nombre de dirigeants des nations
unies ça fait donc l'objet d'une
réprimande pratiquement du secrétaire
général des nations unies alain vasselle
européenne de son fini donc
la sauce monte très haut si l'on peut
dire vous avez aussi des répercussions
américain qui propose de sortir de la
liste de la loi les rites youpi donc là
on commence à voir des sanctions de plus
en plus élevés et une ethiopie qui
commence à s'isoler un tout petit peu au
niveau international comment on peut
expliquer le verrouillage d'information
la part du gouvernement éthiopien
tout simplement parce qu'ils n'ont pas
l'intention de savoir lire tu te
demandes ce qui se passe chez eux il est
apprécié de match et des éthiopiens si
la souveraineté nationale et abyane et
où énormément dessus ils estiment que
c'est leur problème et donc que les
étrangers que ce soit le l'ouest ce
qu'on peut dire les américaines ne sont
ni non pas avoir quelque chose ce qu'il
faut dedans c'est leur problème c'est ce
que répète habite depuis à peu près onze
mois c'est un problème de souveraineté
intérieur donc à partir de ce moment là
ils font ce qu'ils veulent chez eux mais
parler des sanctions qui était apte en
cours qui étaient encore actuellement
mais quels sont les autres moyens de
pression internationale qui pourrait
contribuer au retour de la paix dans
cette région
moi je vous que je ne crois pas trop à
une humiliation quelconque union
africaine a envoyé un envoyé spécial les
etats unis aussi à ben yahmed est
persuadé qu'il a raison que c'est après
la souveraineté intérieur donc il ne
discutera qu'à partir du moment où
peut-être il y aura une grande victoire
sur le terrain si ce qui est entrain de
ce qui est en train de se passer pour
lui après avoir été nommé premier
ministre pour cinq ans il faut une
victoire militaire de manière à mettre
la région du tigré opa si l'on peut dire
donc l'enjeu de ce code de ce conflit
qui vient de redémarrer dans sa
troisième étape si l'on peut dire c'est
que habib ahmed va chercher une victoire
écrasante sur le type i l est les
premières victimes finalement de ce
conflit c'est la population
ce seront la population si on peut lire
mais surtout ceux qui ont été mobilisés
par rabia m depuis trois mois pour
renforcer les larmes ethiopie avait pris
une sévère défaite ce qu'on peut dire
face aux tigres et 1 au mois de juin est
donc là pour l'instant sous l'oeil a eu
énormément de mobilisation dont parle de
400 500 mille personnes sous les armes
si on peut dire et donc les premières
victimes vont être sept ces combats qui
vont être féroce entre les tigres et un
d'un côté et l'armée fédérale aidés par
les milices donc dans un premier temps
seront surtout des nombreux morts parmi
la jeunesse éthiopienne qui motive pour
défendre la souveraineté l'intérieur
comme il ya bien aide et en même temps
vous aurez bien sûr des dégâts
collatéraux vous avez les populations
c'est évident merci beaucoup afrique
ferrasse d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes président chez
stratégie africaine docteur en
géopolitique et spécialiste de la corne
de l'afrique